[Music]
I'm Clarence where I'm from you fight to
survive I'm not a bad person just
playing the cards I was
dealt mom one day I'm going to get you
out of here I have a plan what are we
doing here Jesus lives there
Hallelujah I want to be like that in 10
years I want to be like that
now I need to figure out what inspire
him I can just replicate what he does
imagine the money people will give us
hallu I'm your Uber oh Dead one open
your
eyes what are you trying to prove and
I'm not a nobody you find fi and you
will find all the
ansers parents you are guilty of the
crime fraud for your own ill-gotten
games you give me Jesus of Nazareth I
will let you walk free and I will give
you power wealth you be
somebody I die before I give him up the
Rome then death it is my congregation
going to operate like a corporation I
want my flowers and flower bases I want
carnations I want B I want plun and
flower R I'm a God so you see me say
hallelujah plans in spite of your
selfish ways there's a beautiful soul in
there somewhere Hallelujah I'm a God
when you see me say Hallelujah
Hallelujah Hallelujah
Hallelujah Jesus of Nazareth I'm a God
you see say
hallelujah I'm destined to be
here hallelujah come
on damn
[Music]
hallu